congratulations to you guys cj i'm going
to start with you 14 points you had in
the fourth quarter
just tell me what you were thinking
coming down the stretch i was thinking i
want to play again tomorrow
we had to get this done tonight make
sure we came out and finished them off
we're thankful that we were put in a
position to be able to make the playoffs
and
we didn't want to squander an
opportunity damien we talked about john
moran before the game
the kid just played out of his mind how
did you guys keep him from
single-handedly beating you
we just wanted to make it hard for him
uh obviously he's super explosive
um a lot of speed a lot of athleticism
and you know he has some tough finishes
we just wanted to do our
our best at making it hard for him um
and we did a good enough job to get the
win but like you said he's a hell of a
player
he made some jumpers tonight he got to
the line a few times he was getting to
the rim he made plays
but that's that's why he's a star
already as a rookie uh because of what
he's capable of and
i'm just happy we was able to overcome
that for both of you guys how much of
this was for nurkic playing with a heavy
heart
yeah all of it honestly i can't even
fathom what he's going through you know
having lost some people in my family
you know it's something you never get
over something you just try to get
through so we're just trying to support
him and
understanding that this is a very
difficult time for him and his family
and after the week that you guys have
had
what do you have left for the lakers i
mean i think
you know the reason that we competed so
hard the reason why we fought so hard to
to get in the playoffs
is because we feel like we're capable of
doing you know anything we can beat
anybody
um so now we just got to get rested um
and get ready for the next thing you
know our work is just beginning
and cj you're playing with a broken back
i mean what what do you got left for the
lakers i got a lot left
the good lord has taken back i broke my
back spinal
good lord has taken good care of me uh
i'm i'm getting treatment around the
clock and uh just thankful that it's not
worse than it is
thank you guys good luck in the next
round
all right lisa it's good to see the two
of them smile it has not been an easy
season for the blazers remember last
year they made the conference finals
this year they've had their ups and
downs injuries uneven play
but there have been some performances
from the blazers that their fans will be
talking about for years to come
and perhaps some more ahead as they now
get set to face the la lakers
game one will be tuesday best of seven
first round they're in the 2020
nba playoffs as you look at the western
conference brackets